- My name is Daniela Rus.
I'm the director of the Computer Science
and Artificial Intelligence
Laboratory at MIT,
the place where the future
of computing takes flight.
Our laboratory has deep
roots in two powerhouses,
the AI lab and the laboratory
for computer science.
Now we have a lot of projects at CSAIL
in a lot of different areas, but today
we are going to focus
on our machine friends.
Let's go take a look.
Hello Joseph.
What are you working on today?
- Hi Daniela.
I've been working on some of our wearables
for interacting with robots
and with other animals.
- Why do we want wearables to interact
with robots and animals?
- So we wanna make it easier for anyone
to interact with robots.
And you know, right now
it can be a little hard
to learn the robot's language,
but if we could just use
someone's natural muscle signals
or even their motion or brain signals,
then it could be a lot more intuitive.
- So what does Stretch do today?
- So Stretch is responding
to a lot of the gestures
that I'm making, based on a neural network
processing my muscle signals.
- So can you make Stretch
shake hands with me?
- So if I squeeze my fist,
then Stretch will close its gripper.
- What are we going to use
these intuitive motions for?
- I always wanted a robot to help me
around the kitchen actually. So.
- Like a sous chef?
- Exactly. So we've been
using a lot of wearables
to record how people do kitchen tasks,
like peeling cucumbers, slicing potatoes,
or setting the table, and
then hopefully the robot
can learn from those demonstrations
and those interactions.
- So what else are we working on?
- This is actually a device
that we've been developing
along with Rob Woods' lab at Harvard
and it allows us to probe the mysteries
of how whales actually communicate
and learn more about their culture.
This is placed on a whale and
holds on using suction cups
and then it has a lot
of different sensors.
It has underwater microphones,
it has depth sensors,
temperature sensors, motion sensors,
and maybe even biosignal sensors
that we've been looking at adding.
And this allows us to get
a great multimodal view
of how the whale is behaving and hopefully
we can build up a data set
that lets us understand
more about their language
and their culture.
- How do you collect this data?
How do you attach the tag onto the whale?
- Yeah, so we go out and
we listen for the whales,
using microphones to
find them and then we go
and attach the tag to the
whale, either using a long pole
or using drones, and
we try to be as gentle
and as minimally invasive as possible
so the whales don't really notice it.
We actually had a recent expedition
where we got to be really
close to the whales
and we were lucky enough to
even see a whale giving birth.
- That's amazing. Can you show it?
- Yeah, we actually had a
lot of drones in the air.
We had microphones underwater
and people on the boat.
We were all recording this amazing event
and this is an example
of where I synchronized
all the different
devices so you can see it
from many different angles
and get all of the
different data we recorded.
So we have drone footage
showing it from up above.
We have all our cameras from the boat,
we have the audio recordings
as well as the GPS positions.
So this will hopefully
allow us to learn more
about how they approach
this multi-species event
and celebration.
- Studying artificial
intelligence and robotics
is teaching us a lot, not
just about the technology,
but also about ourselves, about life
and about this wonderful
place we get to live on,
the place Carl Sagan used
to call the pale blue dot.
Let's go check out some
modular robotic cubes.
This way. Hi John.
- Hi Daniela.
- How are you today?
- I'm doing pretty well.
- And how is Belty doing today?
- So Belty is doing pretty good.
He wants to show you a
demo where he picks up
and relocates a block, and
you can sort of imagine this
as like industrial Legos so
that you could have factories
and buildings that sort
of reconfigure themselves.
- Wow, that was amazing.
- So now he's trying to
interface with a different robot
to drop off this block.
- John, that's really very cool.
But why would we want to do this?
- Our current industrial
system is not very flexible,
scalable, and when we have
disruptions like the pandemic
or other disruptions,
basically we can't respond
fast enough to them.
And having factories modular should help
make that more effective.
- So response basically
means making all the products
that we need at the time we need them.
And with a system, we can
begin to imagine factories
that have cell reconfiguring gantries,
where the gantries will
automatically adapt
to the production need.
Right now it takes a
long time to reconfigure
and redesign gantry systems.
With this approach, we will
have much more agile factories.
John, and where do we go from here?
- I think my next step after graduating
is to try to figure out a way
to potentially open source
this idea and get multiple
researchers working together
to create sort of the the specifications
for modular factories.
- Graduation is soon, right?
- Graduation is about a month.
I have a lot of hard work ahead of me.
- Well I look forward
to seeing Belty's feet
in a month's time.
- Thank you.
- Let's go see what's happening
at the robot locomotion lab.
Come on over. Hi Russ.
- Hi Daniela. Welcome to
the robot locomotion group.
- What are you working on today?
- Well we've got robots all around you.
We've been doing a lot
of things over the years.
We do flying robots, as you know.
We do humanoid robots, but these days
we're making robots play with their hands.
- Amazing. Tell me more.
- The world's changing.
We have big generative
AI, and now we're trying
to make sure we understand
how to make generative AI
work for robots with hands,
- You mean you're studying the interaction
aspect of intelligence?
- Yeah, and there's big questions.
We don't really know how much data
is gonna be required to feed this.
We don't know where
we're gonna get the data.
So we already have a couple bets.
One of them is to bet on simulation
plus some really good control
design and simulation.
- Amazing. Can we see some demos?
- We have a bi-manual
robot, which means two arms,
working with two hands,
and doing some complicated
motion planning.
And then I'll show you
something else on a quadruped.
And these are examples
of of really good plans
that we can make slowly,
but generate a lot of data
and feed a data pipeline.
- I'm so excited to see this
integration of language,
perception and control,
which are the hallmarks of intelligence.
- I agree. This here is a bi-manual setup
I was telling you about,
having two robots work
in perfect harmony and
doing complex motions
in and out of obstacles
is still a hard problem.
Tommy here has been really
making a lot of progress
on that and he's gonna
tell you a little bit
about our new experiment.
- If you're holding an object, you sort
of fix your hands together.
So anytime you move one
of the arms, the other
has to move perfectly to stay in sync
or you'll drop the
object, or if it's fragile
you might break it.
So we've been working on some
code that allows us to control
and plan for the robot
arms in a very precise way
so as to accomplish that.
So as you can see here,
we're gonna move each
of the joints individually
in that left arm
and then the right arm has to
take very complicated motions
in order to maintain that constraint.
- So this part isn't the end
goal, this is just showing you
that we've got the map right
and understand how to work
with the hands perfectly in sync.
- And the last bit here,
we can even move one
of the arms without
moving its hand at all.
- Okay, now we wanna show
you the real demo here,
where we put some shelves
up in front of the robot
and make it a little bit more crowded,
so the robot has to figure it out.
- The new planning framework we're using
is something called graph of convex sets.
One of the benefits it gives
us is we can get very strong
collision-free guarantees.
So we know the robot's not
gonna bump into anything.
Normally we're a little uneasy
to bring the robots
this close to obstacles,
but we're so confident in the
methodology we're using here
that we're willing to cut it really close.
And as it's doing this you can see
that it's really maintaining the distance
and the orientation between its hands.
- This is our spot robot
from Boston Dynamics here.
We showed you a little bit about
how we're doing advanced motion planning
with two arms attached to a table.
But we've been working
hard now on trying to get
a mobile manipulator, a legged robot here,
to do the same kind of
beautiful motion plans
but use its entire body.
So let me put this down here on the robot
and see if you can get
Spot to pick it up, David.
- In the following motion, we will have
GCS plan in 25 dimensions
to move back, grab
the little robot and try to
place it between its legs.
- Sounds great.
- Let's do it.
- Why do we care so much
about doing whole body motion
planning on a quadruped here?
- Previously, many
quadrupeds came without arms,
so they do purely locomotion
and don't do much manipulation
in the real world.
On stationary robots, we do
care about collision-free
motion planning and generating fast
and good-looking trajectories
and think it is time
to combine both of that so
we can do mobile manipulation
and have a useful robot, not
only someone mounted on a desk,
but traverse through
(indistinct) environment
and help in other places.
- Yeah, this robot is great.
This can walk all over campus
and now we're gonna make it
so it can manipulate
objects wherever it goes.
- Let's see it move a little bit.
- Looks good. Let's do it.
- Hi Gabe.
- Hi Daniela.
- What are you working on
and who's your new friend?
- In the improbable AI lab here,
we've been working on
different combinations
of locomotion and manipulation.
Previously we were working on Dribble bot,
which is a soccer playing robot.
And now we're really interested
in sort of what happens
if we take this quadruped and
we mount an arm on the top.
- So what's the difference
between this one and Dribble bot?
- This robot is a lot
bigger, and the reason
for its large size is so
it can support the arm,
which is heavier, but the
advantage that we'll have
from using the arm is that we can
actually do some interesting manipulation.
So instead of just kicking
objects with its feet,
the robot can walk
around and touch objects,
which will be useful
in lots of environments
like a kitchen, where
we need to accomplish
some manipulation tasks.
- Can it move the objects around?
Can it plan for how to
organize your kitchen?
- Right now we're really focusing
on the low level controls of the robot.
So how can the walking and
grasping be coordinated?
For example, if the
robot needs to reach up
to a really high cabinet,
it might actually have
to stretch its legs or
even move a small object
to step up on top of
it in order to reach up
to that cabinet.
- So it's learning some gymnastics.
- Yeah, yeah. In a sense.
- Can we see?
- Yeah, we can do a little motion around,
it's actually operated by
a virtual reality headset
and so our operator will move
that arm around a little bit.
- Oh, it's wanting to dance
or stretch or something.
- You can see that if it wants
to reach low to the ground,
it kind of needs to bend its legs down.
- Yeah, it's very interesting.
The control is very smooth.
- Because of the learning-based
approach that we use.
It can avoid some of
the like singularities
that you might get when the arm
is outstretched all that way.
What we're really building I think,
is a teleoperation interface
for providing demonstrations.
And the challenge of course is
that with such a large robot
with high degrees of freedom,
the human operator might have a hard time
telling the robot
exactly what it should do
in every scenario.
- Well, Gabe, you know that
upstairs we have a kitchen
where we're studying how humans perform
the kind of prep tasks
that are needed in cooking.
And perhaps we can get the
robots to be a sous chef
for our human chefs.
- Definitely. I think in
a few months we should
bring 'em up and and give it a try.
- Gabe, that was so awesome.
Thank you so much for
showing us your new friend
and I really look forward
to seeing it in the kitchen helping us.
- Thank you. Looking forward to it too.
- All right, have a nice day. Bye-Bye.
Thank you for joining us
to meet our machine friends at C Cell.
See you on the next tour.